Quantum Computing for computer
scientists autographed
copy Read It and Weep nerds no sanowski
sent me this himself because I am such a
fan of his book The Outer Limits of
reason when people ask me for a
non-fiction recommendation this is what
I say but here are some other books I
have autographed the first book I ever
got autographed was Sharon cree's walk
to moons I was in Middle School when I
met her huzzah huzza before Bill Nye
before beakman there was Mr Wizard the
pop
of Filth John Waters the get rich and
become God method autographed and doodle
in by drill I worked with Dr Judy ho on
Minefield and she sent me this copy of
one of her books but when I looked
inside I saw that it was signed to
Jennifer this is not for me but I didn't
say anything at the time cuz I thought
it was kind of cool and criminal to have
someone else's book but now I feel bad
about it and it's been more than 5 years
so it's really awkward to bring all of
this up and so I'm sorry
Jennifer not